if I quite hear one hundred and fifty
dollars traveling abroad Google wants to
be your personal translator to prove the
point the tech giant's built this type a
street scene to put their software
through its paces I can just take a
photo of the Chinese sign highlight the
piece that I want translator I can see
that this is silk this is Google's view
of the world and it wants you to be at
the heart of it the message we can run
your life from translation and travel to
Heathrow Airport to commuting and
cooking tips Google wants to show it's
more than just a search engine weaving
its way into everything you do ok Google
how many calories in olive oil 884
calories in 100 grams we're using Google
for work to collaborate on documents and
we're posting some things up to our
editor and we're going to have some
video conferences some will point to a
payoff in all of this letting Google
into every corner of our lives gives the
company access to even more of our
personal data but the company is betting
those concerns will be outweighed by the
convenience of our increasingly mobile
lives Tom Mackenzie Bloomberg